and
good morning everybody and welcome to
today's health and well-being board and
happy new year to you all and hopefully
this year will be
an improvement on last year and
now we've got the vaccine and process
rolling out it does feel like
we are making some inroad into the virus
so and you know
fingers crossed that we continue um in
the way
that we have been over the last few
weeks um
alex if we can just uh record apologies
and
we've got apologies from councillor
harding heinz
uh jill mcgregor michelle hill mark
jarvis
caroline hemingway mandy bailey and
sarah radley
because it's a while since we've met do
people want to introduce themselves or
does everybody know everybody
just give me a nod aura
introductions are always helpful yes
okay jane we'll crack on then so i'll
i'll go first and then what i'll do is
i'll
just point people out on my um
screen okay so um i'm councillor jane
slater i'm councillor for stratford ward
and i'm the expect member for health
wellbeing and equality
diane um
thank you councillor slater i'm diane
the corporate director
for adults and well-being in traffic
council
gene hi i'm gene i'm the vice chair of
healthwatch trafford
councillor holden
thanks gene uh councillor john holden
said mary's award in sale
maury morning maureen noble independent
chair of the strategic safeguarding
partnership
heather
you're on mute
um i'm heather fairfield i'm the chair
of healthwatch trafford
ben
i've got a kid just in front of me i'm
ben thomas i've managed to customer
support and creative solutions
teams for trafford house and trust thank
you
eleanor hi i'm eleanor roof i'm director
of public health for trafford
sally hi i'm sally johnston i'm chair of
the ccg
alice
i'm hi i'm alex i'm the medical director
from gmmh
i have been here in the background
without a picture on previously
um we finally managed to get access to
zoom
brilliant mick
yeah mick gallagher director of
independent living care and support with
trafford housing trust
thank you martin
sorry joe you surprised me there going
around in a different order on your
screen than it is
hello everybody i'm martin pritchard i'm
the accountable office for nhs trafford
ccg and chair i've got an apology which
is
i certainly need to go at 11 30 because
stein and i have got a um our daily call
with our health and social care
partners so i'm sorry about that but i
do need to leave at that time well if we
whip through it
martin we may be finished on time uh
jane
councilor james beverly hello i'm
councillor jane brophy i represent
timperley ward
dorothy hi i'm dorothy evans ceo for the
african caribbean care group
and the csc representative
council linda blackman hello yeah linda
blackburn
i'm shadow exec member for health
wellbeing and equalities good morning
jackie i can see you there at the bottom
sorry i couldn't unmute and i'm just
having to switch the video on as well do
you apologize
morning everybody uh my name is jackie
coulton i'm chief nurse for traffic ccg
thank you very much and and we have alex
from and
from the committee do you want to say hi
alex or
is that okay it's fine but
alex murray governance officer thank you
okay so um if we can move on please um
item two is the terms of reference and
those have been um
circulated previous um prior to the
meeting so
uh they're just for noting today so um
is that okay with everybody to move on
from that
okay um also for noting we've circulated
the board membership for
2021 so if there are any people feel
that we've missed somebody off or there
should be something included if you can
just let us know we will
make sure that those those people are
included
and item four is um the minutes from the
last time we met which was on the 16th
of october
it feels like a lifetime ago but only
a matter of a few months so um if those
can be agreed or if there are any uh
matters arising if people want to let us
know now
how can we agree then
okay agreed thank you um i don't believe
we've had
um any questions from the public and
which is item five
and can we move on to item six please
which is um declarations of interest
does anybody have any declarations of
interest
a lot of shaking heads so i don't
believe we have thank you everybody
and if we can then move on to the
substantive agenda which is item seven
uh refreshing the health and well-being
board strategy and obviously in the
light of everything that's been going on
so
um eleanor you are gonna lead this
discussion please
hello sorry oh hi doc
honey hi
hi okay so um there's several
um pieces of work all tied into this
and i'm going to start off i sent yet um
there was a
one-pager sent round which i'll just
quickly run through
and then we can look at um three
documents that if you like
underpin that and the explanation for it
so
i'll start by running through what i i
consider
the health and well-being strategy to be
currently um
and then we have three document three
related documents
that i think help us put it in a better
context
take us to where we're going to need to
be over the next
few years bearing in mind some fairly
major changes to
bits of system and also link it into
other pieces of work that are going on
in the council so the very specific one
that i've pulled in for today is the
equality
strategy but we also have the poverty
strategy within the council
which again has very strong links to all
of our work so what i'm trying to do is
um so if i start by taking you through
my
the one one-page document uh which i
hope people have had a chance to read
but if i just um refresh your memory on
it so we we did a
new version of our health and well-being
board strategy in 2019
um and we continued with our previous
theme which was
to continue to try and reduce our
internal inequalities as hell
in healthy life expectancy on the
grounds that that was the thing that was
going to make the biggest difference
to our population in trafford and will
pick up those internal inequalities that
we see
that often get missed if we just focus
on traffic's overall performance
particularly when we consider trafford's
overall performance in the context of
greater manchester
and i've spent a lot of time i think at
this board saying to people
it's not so much about our performance
compared to greater manchester it's
it's our performance compared to our um
uh
our other statistical neighbors other
areas that are more like us because we
are very unlike the rest of greater
manchester
this year however i think one of the
things it has taught us is that we are
very much part of greater manchester for
all sorts of reasons because obviously
a um a uh an infectious disease
does love a geography uh more than a
statistical neighbor
so where we have really seen this year
is how much we are part of greater
manchester
and um and the impact of of our
practices
on the rest of greater manchester and
theirs on ours so particularly for
example we import and many many people
come into our borough
to work in trafford park many people
will live in our borough and work
elsewhere
and with as i say with an infectious
disease that those
those travel patterns and that that
geographical closeness
is really important to us so it's been a
it's been a i think a a well a wake-up
call that we do keep needing to remember
our geography as well as our
other demographics so but having said
that
and over thinking about what we've been
learning from covid
it's made covert has made massive
changes to the way we we live and the
way that services have been delivered
but overall the learning from covid is
very much still in line with what we
were thinking about as a health and
wellbeing board before it
before any of this happens so we we
continue to see
that those our preoccupations remain the
same
it is about the inequalities people from
more deprived backgrounds have been much
harder hit
by covid it is about the other aspects
of people's lives the underlying health
conditions and how we reduce the risk of
people having
underlying health conditions such as
diabetes so the work that we need to be
doing
to make sure that people are a healthy
weight that they're not misusing alcohol
that they're not smoking and
particularly making sure that we have
that drop in smoking
which um and beanish i'm sure we'll be
able to talk about this
we've see we've seen a drop in smoking
very welcome drop in smoking in our
routine and manual workers
but our rates in our people with serious
mental illness remain extremely high
and i think again the covert issues on
mental health
the attention that that's brought to
everybody about our mental health and
the importance of good mental health
and the number of people we're seeing
with really quite severe
serious mental health conditions um that
have either been exacerbated during
covet or people who have have
experiencing serious mental health
problems for the first time
at this time has been a massive massive
um uh shock and horror i think to us all
um and i know a lot of people have have
um
have been you know wrestling with how we
do how we
how we manage this how we manage the
mental health impact of a physical
illness
um reducing physical inactivity again
all of these tie down to reducing your
risk from cardiovascular disease from
cancer
and from covered the impact of mental
illness and we remain in trafford and
outlier on this our performance for
people with serious mental illness
is worse than our other statistical
neighbors we have more people dying
prematurely than we should
um with serious mental illness and we do
absolutely need to
keep that mental i think i think one of
the big learnings for us about about
covid is that mental health illness side
um the general inequalities as well
within all of this again the ethnicity
dimension has been absolutely something
we've all been talking about of this
board
but again something that's been
enormously strongly brought to the
for that link between ethnicity and
deprivation
and the huge impact that that has had on
a substantial number of our population
so i think
what we need to be doing as well and
thinking about is that we we've quite
often
i think over this last year we've
slipped into a debate between
the economy and health and you know
why we're protecting health and damaging
the economy and i think
i think we have to stop trying to see
these two things as a dichotomy they're
not a dichotomy if you don't have a
healthy workforce
you don't have a workforce so we have to
make sure that we
do everything we can to make our our
workforce healthy and resilient
to make sure we've got the health and
social care systems that can withstand
pressure because the previous year
we were under pressure in the health
system you know we were we have been
running on empty i think as a country
for a little while
and we need to be thinking about how we
do how we do build that back and
understand how we get that better more
resilient population so that we can
better
cope with the things that will be coming
to us because
as we all saw with floods last week
where i think we had the worst flooding
um in in trafford the highest levels
that we've seen
and these will get worse with climate
change we have to address that
and i think one of the one of the i mean
many of the things that
i think have been brought to the fore
from covid are things that actually
by tackling the risk the covid risk we
actually tackle the other societal risks
as well
the one thing i would say is is really
difficult for us at the moment is that
active travel
and public transport and the impact of
public transport
for covid because we were personally i
was really seeing
the role of public troop transport in um
helping us with our climate change
issues and sustainability issues
as being a massive part but i think
people's faith in public transport will
be damaged for quite some time
and so that again reinforces our need to
think about we
we have no option but to get cars off
the road from air quality point of view
from sustainability point of view from
carbon reduction point of view we have
to get cars off the road and that means
we do need to start really thinking now
about how we manage to get more people
traveling actively
so that the roads feel safe and that
people can cycle and walk
because some people we absolutely cannot
have those people who were in
uh buses and trains previously going
into private cars
we would there is no no way we will meet
our carbon reduction
targets or our air quality targets if we
increase our
numbers of people driving so all of
these contacts
i think pull together and
for me i feel that what kovit has shown
us
is that our health and wellbeing board
strategy was the right strategy
but what we need to be doing is using
the impetus and the learning and the
energy if you like and the determination
not to stay in the place we are now
to make give us that energy and hope for
change so that we can really start
putting forward
a positive vision of where we want to be
not just
a world where we're able to party again
which is will be
fantastic we're able to travel but one
where actually we reduce the risk of
anything like this happening again
and we increase our possibility of our
the probability
that our population will be healthy
enough to withstand it and that we won't
see the glaring inequalities
yet again coming through with our
poorest people paying the price
for choices that we're all making so
with that in mind that is my summary of
i'm saying to you i would like us to
stay with the same goal
i would like us to really focus on that
inequalities and the driving down of the
inequal internal inequality
in trafford and i'm now going to move i
think
rather than do it quite in order unless
well i'll take any questions now
but otherwise what i was going to
suggest is we um
i've got we've got three other documents
we've got a presentation
on the changes that are happening in the
nhs i think that might be
helpful to have that first we've also
got
the public health annual report which i
will present to you
um but this is uh is still in its final
draft form there are still typos which
is why it's not been
yet on the website but it has been
circulated to board members
um and we've got the equality strategy
which has just been signed off by the
um the council and the ccg
so i'm not quite sure what order people
want to take those in but if we have if
i pause for breath i know i've
lectured you for long enough and i will
hand back to the chair for any questions
um thank you elena and if anybody does
have any questions if they can indicate
and or any comments on what eleanor said
but i do think it was
it's pertinent that you talked about the
equality strategy and the poverty
strategy
uh being looked at in tandem and on um
on wednesday at full council we actually
declared a poverty emergency within
trafford because we have
seen such deprivation and sadness and
loss for our people in our
most deprived areas so um you know i
think that this is a really important
time
to be making sure that equality and the
poverty strategy
are at the fore of everything that we do
within the borough so that we don't
leave people behind so thanks thanks for
that eleanor does anybody have any
comments or
questions for allah on what she's said
so far
heather yeah hi um
i think that really and the last couple
of times i've heard you
uh speak helena you've you've talked
about
mental health which is you know is one
of uh healthwatch's
um priorities um and i'm pleased to see
that you describe it in the way that you
do
because i'm not sure that the
seriousness with which you
take it actually permeates throughout
the rest of the organization
um and you know we're making really
slow progress um in terms of getting a
strategy for trafford and i've been
advocating this now
for the last three or four years so it's
not anything
uh that's new um so i'd really like
some impetus really now behind
uh mental health because it's uh
it it's a it's an indictment really on
us that
um you know it's as bad as it is
the second point really is that um
both alice and i were at a a meeting
yesterday of gm
mental health and um we now know that
there is a new mental health strategy
going to be published by the end of
march and we also know and this links in
with
an item later on when we're talking
about the ics
we also know that there is a new uh
governance structure uh about to be
implemented from uh the first of april
so if you've not seen any of that uh
detail eleanor i'm quite happy to
uh uh to let you have what i can
thanks
thank you heather um councillor brophy
you indicated you'd like to
come in just a quick question
on something eleanor said the
clarification
did i hear correctly that the deaths in
trafford
with people with mental health is higher
um if i did hear that correctly i just
wondered if
more information on the reasons would
that be i think
i think you said that they were higher
than other areas um
is that due to smoking or are there
other underlying reasons there
so um what we look at with people with
serious mental illness
and i think you know we take we do a
measure of premature mortality which is
deaths before the age of 75
and what we see with people with serious
mental illness is that their premature
mortality rate is much higher
than the general population some of that
most of that is due to
other underlying so other so other
behaviors such as smoking or alcohol use
so a number of the issues are related to
smoking for example the risk factors
that smoking give
but what we also know is that people
with serious mental illness find want to
give up smoking
and exactly the same proportions as the
rest of the population
but sometimes need more support to do so
so what we
what we know with people serious mental
illness is that often their physical
health
is is not taken seriously seriously
enough and we're not giving enough
support to people to
to maintain really good physical health
with mental
when they have a serious mental illness
so it's it's there
will be a combination of factors but
often that they often there will be
prevent absolutely preventable causes
of those deaths so i i did hear that
correctly i thought i heard you say that
it was
it was worse in traffic than other areas
so i test the idea that people with
serious mental health problems have a
lower mortality but i wanted to ask
specifically
why is it even worse in trafford so i
think it's a combination of reasons and
i think
again it ties into the the work that
heather's um alluding to i think we
really do need to get underneath the
reasons for it and making sure
that we're getting people into
preventative services as quickly as they
can we can etc
so that we can make a real difference to
that population
and the engagement with that population
so i i would see that piece of work very
much fitting into the overarching mental
health strategy for
for the borough
and there's some dates in i'm aware of
the some dates in the calendar for that
work to start
i think they're coming up quite soon on
the other so and yeah that is going to
be
um something that we look at very very
closely um
council blackburn did you want to come
in yes thank you
i just wanted to just comment about the
you know the use of
either uh public transport or
people's you know pri private vehicles i
think
as a result of covid there are going to
be
more people working from home perhaps
not on a permanent basis but
the so i think the impact of that will
be
less use of public transport less use
of private cars for travelling but
i think there's a good possibility of an
increase in mental health issues
due to isolation because um you know in
individuals will be usually working on
their own at home
and working at home can be a lonely
thing you know you don't have the
interaction of
you know of people by the you know bad
the kettle the water bouncing or
whatever
so in a way it's a it's a double-edged
sword
you know you might have to sort of it
better than one and work worse than
another can you comment elena
i completely agree with you and i think
as well as the the risk of isolation for
some people working from home
there's a very real risk of a failure of
isolation for some other people when
you're trying to home educate your
children at the same time for example
and dealing with the other pressures of
family life um
so the the the and and i think
the other thing i think for for working
from home is that
where you already have the relationships
with people and whether you already know
people that's
it's not so difficult to maintain those
when you're when you're on
um video calls and so on but if you what
i'm finding
i think a number of us finding is when
you get new people
joining who don't know people already
how you manage to get
oops
you're frozen elena
says yeah we got that
so if you say well you're making up your
whatever
you know all of that is is really
important part of
um being being in work developing those
trusted relate you know
and understanding people and getting
those trusted relationships
because most of our work isn't actually
about the transactional nature of the
work it is about the quality of the
relationships
we have with people that we work with
isn't it that's that's how we get our
work done
by by the conversations we have and by
sometimes the chance remarks that you
hear
somebody is doing a piece of work with
something and you say oh well that you
know that would work well with what i'm
doing
so i'm my my real worry about some of
this
for the working from home is how do we
we've got we might all be the bricks but
how do we get the mortar
to hold us together and what do we how
do we make that work
and it it's a learning time for us all i
think
but absolutely linda you are completely
right about the mental health impacts of
all of this
and i think as a council and where
people have indicated to the managers
that they're having difficulty from
working from home we've
been able to secure safe working for
them in
office space and i'm sure that there are
a lot of employers doing that but yeah
and the isolation of working from home
is is very difficult for um
employees and if everybody's
sort of had the contribution on that
should we move on to um
the next item i think we'll bring in
martin at this point to give us an
update on the ccg
system thanks martin
thank you chair and just on that
final point absolutely agree with
eleanor um
some people will know my colleague um
gareth james who is our director of
finance
in nhs trafford ccg he's actually just
uh he's been working for us for six
months now
i've never met gareth i didn't meet him
during the interview because we
interviewed him on teams and i've never
actually met one of my key colleagues
despite the fact we've worked together
now for
six months um and it just reflects how
hard it is to
continue to work in in this way isn't it
despite the wonderful technology that we
have
so um what you've got in front of you is
a paper that i think many of you will
have seen because this has been
discussed in
a lot of different places and you'll
probably be really
pleased to hear that i don't intend to
go through this slide by slide
and bullet point by bullet point i'm
just guessing that might be the case
what i'm just going to do is uh pick out
a few key things because always in these
situations
it's the conversation and isn't it and
the questions you get get the value from
so before christmas there was a national
engagement exercise that
asked for questions about how we would
propose to shape how the nhs works going
forward
and as nhs trafford we responded to that
to those questions and we said yep we
support the direction of traveling
and yes we absolutely want as much as
possible to be decided locally
rather than nationally on this and i
know that trafford council
jane you put in a similar response from
the council and indeed across greater
manchester
um all of the councils and nhs bodies
came together and put in a joint
response and said yeah absolutely we
support
that way the the key thing for me and
diane and i have talked about this a lot
is
what this supports is the work that we
are doing in trafford
about the further integration of how we
work in health and social care across
trafford
and what we need to do is we need to use
these changes
to support what we were doing anyway and
what we plan to do anyway through our
locality plan
and our focus on people place and
partnerships in that
so what the paper sets out is it sets
out for the work what we're doing in
five key areas
the the system board um the overall
partnership board that will hold this
together and we see that as a
development
of our um joint commissioning board that
we've had in traffic sometime
the provider collaboratives the way in
which we'll work together in future both
what we currently call our local care
alliance and our local care organization
and a number of the people on this call
are part of those meetings and
conversations already
and in a moment i'm going to bring dr
sally johnson in our
chair because sally's involved in one of
the key aspects of this is
how do we bring together the clinical
and professional leadership in this
to develop on what we've had and what
we've been doing and finally what we've
got in there
is um the transition piece of work
because
what this means and it is all subject to
primary legislation is subject to
parliament
um agreeing these changes what this will
mean is in
14 months so the first of april 2022
there will no longer be
a nhs trafford commissioning
organisation and those functions will be
done by
health and social care organizations
continuing to work together
so i hope that's a helpful introduction
chair
i know a number of people have seen this
had this conversation before so i don't
want to label it i'd rather have
the questions and conversations and i
would invite
um sally if she wants to add anything
about the clinical and professional
leadership at this stage or maybe maybe
later
thank you chair thanks martin
um very exciting times to try and
re-figure and rebuild
the clinical professional relationships
we have i think um
for a long time um doctors have been
siloed both secondary care doctors and
primary care doctors
um in their own little work spaces quite
isolated from some of the other primary
care colleagues such as the pharmacist
and the dentist and the optometrist
and then of course with our social care
colleagues that are looking after many
of our most vulnerable patients
brilliantly in the community so
alongside
dr mark jarvis who's the medical
director of traffic ccg
we're trying to bring together
colleagues from
the medical the nursing the social care
the wider primary care community
and work out what could how that could
look best
for trafford going forward um we were
due to get started on this
with impetus and unfortunately you may
have noticed there has been
a fairly um impressive mass vaccination
campaign that is going brilliantly in
trafford
but it is taking up a lot of time um
so we will get round to it in the little
gap i think we have between the first
doses which will probably be completed
by about six weeks and then we'll start
the second doses a couple of weeks after
that
but um it's trying to look at things
with a fresh pair of eyes and do things
better um
i agree with everything that's been said
so far and i've moved away from the
phrase building back better which
i hope we do but i think building back
fairer i think the inequalities in
trafford
are enormous and shameful really because
i've sat around a lot of meetings in the
last two to three years and these aren't
new ideas
these have been there for a long long
time and
at some point we can't just talk about
them we have to try and change them
and so far although there's a lot of
talking going on and a lot of good ideas
being done
um the change hasn't been there so
perhaps we just all need a refresh
and a new way of looking at things and i
think the more holistic approach the
more people around the table will be
better
that's me thank you sally martin did you
want to
add anything else are you happy to take
questions or comments now
okay and does anybody have any questions
for martin or sally
jay this is alrighty fine coming it's
diane
thank you and i think it's really
important as we move into this space now
that the health and well-being board and
the role
that we play on setting the strategy
across traffic is is
is strengthened and one of the things
that ellen and i have been talking
through
with martin as well is is how we bring
for the board that visibility so
um as part of eleanor's presentation
today i think it's really helpful that
the
strategy is then refreshed based on the
on the two
or three reports that you're receiving
today and future reports such as the
poverty strategy
and then the second phase of that is to
really identify where each of the
pieces of work are then being completed
within our structural systems
and so that the board knows who is doing
what and when they can expect to see
outputs and the board hold that higher
level performance information that says
and shows where we are making an impact
on healthy
uh and long lives for our residents
so that's how we're going to hopefully
try and take the world on this journey
and over the next few months
thank you diane um does anybody
have anything that they'd like to ask or
comment on
i know that maureen and heather have
been putting some comments in the chat
around
and the mental health stuff so if we can
pick up on
those points and and either respond
after today or um anybody's able to
respond
now i've i've responded to
more in the in the chat on the mental
health strategy so yes very much all age
we're very
very keen to make sure that our
children's mental health is um is
properly
understood and well catered for and i
mean i think that's been a major concern
again
through throughout um kovid and and
picking up diane's point i think we
and and sally's we have spent a lot of
time saying the same
things and it does feel like we may now
have a structure in the system that we
can actually start delivering it
but we have to want to do it it's not
going to happen on its own and it will
mean doing some things very differently
and focusing in different ways
and paying attention to some different
indicators
and not you know i think i think we've
we've often been in a situation where
our acute
situation is so dire that we um
we can't it's very difficult to find the
headspace for the prevention work
and in fact this year i've been in
exactly that situation because all of
the public health work
at the moment has been in that response
mode we have been absolutely focused
on what we're doing to keep keep to keep
things going to reduce the risk to our
population
to minimize the harm that's being done
so i
interestingly this year have been in the
position of being the person who's
saying i don't care what you're wanting
to do next year what we need to do
this week is um so it's been it's been a
change for me
but i do think as well it is just that
thinking about
every time we don't do something that
gets us closer to reducing those
inequalities
we increase the inequality it we
we don't it it gets worse not better so
we have to
we have to do this now and we have to
make sure that we're held to account
for the right things and that for me is
where i want to see the health well and
well-being board
i want us to be the people who are
holding the service delivery the service
models to account and say
why haven't why hasn't it changed why
are we still
seeing this level of deprivation
this level of smoking this level of
domestic abuse why are these still
happening in these populations
in these areas and why haven't we
changed it
and making you know making that we have
if it has felt to me
for a while really in trafford that the
health and well-being boards has been in
the nice to do
list not the must-do list and nothing
that and and
very much nobody disagrees with anything
we say in the health and well-being
board
but nobody thinks not everybody thinks
that we have to act on it now
and i think with climate change with the
and we have i mean obviously last year's
annual report was on climate change
we do need to be thinking about the way
we were
is not the way we can continue to be
that is not that is not an
option for us so how are we going to be
different and how do we lead that
difference and how do we
how do we send that message out really
firmly and reward people for doing the
thing that's hard and different now
rather than slipping back into our old
ways
sorry bit of a rant thank you elena and
counselor brophy did you have a comment
just a question i know that heather's
team at healthwatch have done some
good work in this area already and i
want to ask a question about the impact
of
the chronic fatigue that we're seeing
with long covid
i'm aware there's quite a large
population hidden of people who have
chronic fatigue who
don't always engage just due to the
nature of the condition
but with chronic fatigue being part of
the long-covered syndrome i wonder
if there's a strategy to look at how we
manage that going forward
so i know that the ccg are doing a lot
of work on this
so i'm sure sally or um martin will want
to comment on that but and i think it's
really important that we do many
we do link the the the other post viral
syndromes in
with with the developments we need
around some of those um
um physiotherapy occupational therapy et
cetera services but i'm sure sally will
be able to talk more about it
yeah the long covered work is going on
jointly between manchester
and trafford currently but i think this
is another area where moving forward
once we have a gm
ics some of the works around chronic
fatigue
will be much better shared across the
greater manchester footprint because
traffic's quite a small ccg and doesn't
really have
facilities to fully fund and support a
service i know there's quite a good one
in stockport but it is something that
a gm offer would be much much better
and then we also have obviously um
equitable access across the whole of gm
because currently it's a bit of a
postcode lottery because these services
get quite overwhelmed
so if we haven't got it in trafford
sometimes the our neighboring localities
won't let us refer into their service
which is disappointing for patients that
require help
so there's a lot of work being done on
long covered hopefully you can build on
that across the gm footprint for the
chronic chronic fatigue as well
sorry thanks sorry thanks for that sally
and
alice did did put um a comment in the
chat that there was some gm work so
hopefully it'll be good to see that
going forward if we can move on then as
nobody else has any other comments or
questions for
oh heather's waving go on heather
hi yeah just two or three points really
and the first one is that two years ago
we did a a huge exercise on chronic
fatigue
syndrome and we've had responses from a
thousand people
not only in gm but
in across the uk and also abroad
and we published our recommendations on
chronic fatigue i wouldn't want that to
be
um forgotten uh really and we did that
with manchester university so it was a
very useful and
authoritative report with some
recommendations
as to how we move forward and of course
with long covered
um it it sort of reinforces
uh the need to perhaps re revisit that
and the next point i wanted to make was
about uh
inequalities and and we're well on a way
now
through uh doing uh this work on
inequalities with
uh north trafford and we have engaged
with about 100 different people
and groups and and hopefully over the
next few weeks we'll be able to come
back
with some good information for you
and then the third point really was one
of
um really just um i suppose
congratulating the ccg
in the terms of uh i was at a gm
healthwatch meeting yesterday and i can
tell you that
no other ccgs have approached their
health watch
regarding ics and what will happen
whereas we've certainly been approached
and been asked to give
recommendations which we've done so um
just so that it doesn't seem i was
moaning er
i know to congratulations martin on that
thank you thank you heather
and if we can now move on please ellen
did you want to
um look at refreshing the health and
well-being board strategy oh no sorry
yeah so what i what i'm going to try and
do now is share my screen
and um i don't know if it will work
and just quickly run through the both
the um
public health annual report for this
year and also the inequalities
the equality strategy talk about both of
those
um although i i know jane will give a
better presentation of the equality
strategy
than i have because i i heard her giving
a very very
excellent preamble to it for the
council meeting the other day um but i
suppose what i think maybe
for now and for today given the
pressures on everybody's time and given
given what we need to be doing i think i
think where i'm wanting to end up
from this meeting is for us to
understand
how we're going to fit this work do we
agree that this is the work we need to
be doing and secondly how do we fit this
work
into everybody else's work plans so that
we get groups that can undertake can
make sure that the work is being
progressed
effectively efficiently and quickly
through the other pieces of work and
through those other changes so that we
really embed this work into the work of
our local
system board of our local care alliance
and of our general
provider function delivery function and
as well pick up those roles around our
partnerships
where we can see where things for
example housing
education and the environment
are can play their part in making sure
that everybody's lives in trafford is
better
so i'm going to see if i can share my
screen
is that working can you see
anything there yes thank you so this is
the annual report and i'm just
really going to spin through it we've
just had it back this week so it's full
of
um typos still i'm afraid um but we'll
get it out to you
but what i've done with this year's
annual report is just go
through some of the issues that we have
identified
within uh what covert has taught us
about trafford
and about our lives now so the biggest
risk so if we talk about
um you know i think it this time last
year
public the public health team were
getting very anxious about
um the possibility of a pandemic and
most people were still at the point of
saying
get over yourselves this isn't going to
happen and i
i was reflecting we were reflecting the
other day what would we have
done if we'd known this time last year
where we would be now in a way i'm glad
we didn't because i think it would have
been a very very difficult
thing for us to think about um in a way
it's been better to
to live through it not knowing than um
than to have
to really how quickly this came upon us
how fast we had to react and how well
we've reacted in many
ways you know there are things we we
could have done better obviously there
are things we could have done much
better
but there are things we've done well so
it is making sure that we don't
we don't think everything has been
terrible so in this i think the main
thing for this board is really
that the issues about who the virus is
affecting the most
and it's that um it's age
it's deprivation it's those chronic
underlying conditions so what we've
looked at in
in the annual reporters is how our
population has been affected by age
these are the death rates
so you can see our death rates in
trafford you know really almost all of
those deaths in our various oldest
population
and the risk of death reducing very
dramatically
as as we go down the age ranges
we've now i mean this was written
literally six weeks ago and so much has
changed
um these are the diagnosis rates
again by age and sex with men
being far more severely affected by
covert than women
again men often have more underlying
health conditions
more likelihood of cardiovascular
disease
often more alcohol use more higher rates
of smoking
but again this impact on on men and our
need to make sure that we can get
men to engage with their health and
understanding how to keep themselves
healthy
is a really big thing for us i think as
a borough
we can't just leave health as being
something that that women worry about
or that women have to manage for a
family it we have to have
much much more engagement with men about
how to get
better to manage their health better
deprivation
again we've talked about this at length
and ethnicity
no it's not at all obvious that there
are any
biological reasons for the difference in
um
the death rates and the serious illness
by ethnicity
so it does seem to be it is about um the
way we structure our society that has
left many of our
um people from being backgrounds
particularly from
some black backgrounds and british
bangladeshi pakistani origin people at
much higher risk for all sorts of
reasons
but it is about how again about how we
structure ourselves and the risk of
deprivate and the
the huge risks with deprivation and
again that interface between
for example ethnicity and higher
deprivation risk
rates has really made made a difference
to the
to the experience of people and the
people again people who are
dying of covid are very highly linked to
some of the lower paid face-to-face
occupations
so much more likely to be the nursing
auxiliaries and nursing assistants than
the nurses and the doctors
so again all that deprivation and
often precarious employment for some of
these groups really making a difference
to people's ability
to manage their covid risk effectively
because they effectively have very very
little way of managing it i think
and long-term conditions again big risks
to do with long-term conditions and
particularly around obesity which
we have really struggled with as a
society and
two-thirds of our adult population are
now overweight or obese
and the indications are that during
covid rather than
thinking about the obesity risk that
kovid brings
to um that the obesity risk from covid
actually people have been getting fatter
and again that home working and so on
probably
means that people are taking sometimes
taking less exercise people being more
anxious about going out
does again mean that people are losing
that physical activity
and that again is a huge risk factor
uh
and more likely to have issues
intergenerational housing is fine if you
can space yourself out
but if you're all over crowded that
intergenerational housing does give a
risk
um and racism and the poor experience of
health care
and the lack of trust in systems and i
think again one of the things that's
come out and it picks up the mental
health issues again
that many of our communities actually
have really come together have done
fantastic work we've seen that with the
community hubs we've seen that
in neighbours setting up zoom and
setting up whatsapp groups for their
streets really looking out for each
other
there has been a lot of really really
good community spirit community
engagement
but what we have found is with some of
our com communities particularly where
there's low trust in
wider systems and at a reliance on your
family and friends and particularly your
family
as your most trusted
sources of support and a mistrust of
some of the external sources
what we see then is that trust has
actually meant that those people have
continued to use their families for that
support
and but they have failed to see
and we all fail to see this that often
in a communicable disease obviously it's
the people that we trust the most
who are the biggest danger to us so by
having that
by have by having your care delivered by
somebody you really trust
you may not keep that social distance
from them where if there's somebody from
outside coming in you're able to manage
that relationship in a different way
so it is about thinking about sometimes
in this situation
having those very tight-knit family
communities which are really powerful
and really positive
many many ways actually has exposed
people to increase risk
so it's thinking about how do we make
sure that people
are able to trust the wider community so
that they can get the support they need
and not feel that they have to that that
they um
i'll have to be completely reliant on on
their own family
while at the same time absolutely
absolutely recognizing and acknowledging
the huge role that we all we all and the
support we all get from our families
but how do we support people to to get
that help safely
um mental health huge features so the
other aspects in this
um are we've done a section on the
mental health aspects of covid
and the the difficulties particularly
with people for people with long-term
mental health conditions
um some practical steps around mental
well-being but again a big section on
here um heather as we were talking
previously
about mental health and the other big
section is on children in young people
and the huge impact on children and
young people
of a disease that is highly unlikely to
cause them
any direct harm and our children and
young people have had immense disruption
to their lives and a year for a child is
really different from a year to an adult
if you're
if you're 55 one year is 155th of your
life but if you're 10 it's a tenth of
your life that's a massive difference
so we've put a big section in in the
report on on
on our children and our young people and
how we manage to
to think about how we get that that get
support our young people make sure that
they are able to catch up and that all
of them are able to catch up because
again
the inequalities are massive here and
sally i'm sorry i have called it
building back better and um i might
we're still in the final edit of this so
i might use your wording
but there is looking at how we do
housing better
thinking about how people on low incomes
and precarious employments are supported
better again tying into the poverty
strategy
how we improve people's working
conditions and i'm
cons at the moment what i'm seeing is
some you know we we hear a lot about
individuals breaching covert
but there are a lot of employers who
could be doing more and should be doing
more we really do need to get our
employers
to to some of our employers have been
absolutely excellent and the two groups
i would really want to single out for
amazing work
are our schools and our care homes who
could not have worked harder or done a
better job
through all of this absolutely
phenomenal work
and i really wish some of our other big
employers across trafford
would take a leaf out of some of their
books because i think they have a lot to
learn from them
um we've talked about supporting
behavior change you've talked about the
reducing inequalities and i think this
has got to be
the area that this our group our health
and wellbeing board absolutely has to be
focusing on
how do we get those behavior changes
down reducing those inequalities
one of the stark things from from the
traffic
the work we've seen is that the
the impact of our of say obesity
or poor diabetes management on covert
risk
and actually some of that is completely
within our control to manage now and we
do need to get on top of it
tackling climate change he knew i
wouldn't do anything without talking
about climate change and then we've got
a little section on on what we want to
do as a borough
so that and some and also i've put in
some calls for national changes minimum
unit prices sugar tax how can we
possibly lose weight if we don't start
taxing people's
the sugar use we've got to get the food
industry on this
investment in health and social care and
our active travel back to active travel
so that is the conclude that is our
that's my report
um i
what do i do i commend it to you and we
will you've had a copy of it
um people on the board have had a copy
already
uh we would welcome comments and what i
would like us to do
is be able to take both this and our
equality strategy
to get an action plan that we can then
give to where we
ask the what i would like us to do is
ask the system board and the lca
to develop an action plan that delivers
against those goals
thank you elena and i've read the report
it's really you know it is excellent
it's it touches everything that we want
to do
as a as a borough going forward and i do
like um
sally's wording of building back bearer
i think that um
we might have to steal that from her and
put that in there i think it's an
excellent turn so
does anybody have any comments or
questions that they would like to ask
eleanor about the um
report
yeah i'd just like to say um it was a
good read
i think covid has highlighted and
brought to the forum
a lot of the issues in particular the um
the health inequalities uh in relation
to poverty and
you talk about you know the or
recognizing the fact that we
have intergenerational families people
more people are caring now less people
are taking up the vaccine
and i just ask how do we support people
who have greater caring roles um
and acknowledge them in terms of the
support that they actually need
i think we we recognize that they are
doing all of this extra work
but there's no recognition as how we
can support them because they are
more they they are they are essentially
um
carers now absolutely and i know diane
and sally and martin will all want to
come in on this one but i think
one of the things from all of this is of
is that we've been trying to make sure
that we get lists of carers that we
understand we've got a carers
partnership we've got a carers center
the gps have lists of people who have
caring responsibilities
and i think one of the things from this
is just trying to make sure that we've
got those all of those lists up to date
and that the
that we've got the reach into our
different communities for that carers
work so that people
because so that people from every
different community can see the benefit
of engaging with the carers partnership
and other groups
because it gives them benefit so i think
we need to make sure that the
the work we're doing with our carers um
is the work that our carers will find
most helpful and i'm sure
diane i know will want to comment on
that and
we relaunched the um carers partnership
board this week
young carers who are trying to work you
know hope
to be home schooled and actually care
for um adults or or siblings within the
within the family unit and we
you know that is that is going to be a
massive issue for some of those young
people
trying to learn so from at the carers
board
there were things that came forward and
hopefully we will be able to
um bring some of that back to this board
to explain where where
we need to be with with carers and i
think there needs to be a recognition
from government actually
that you know when people are caring
they need to have
some sort of support you know some
financial support as well as
you know other support but i think there
needs to be some proper financial
support because there are people who are
caring
you know who don't receive any sort of
allowances or support to be able to
continue to do that so
i think we need to call on government as
well to be able to do something around
carers for us
but diane sorry do you want to come in
and it's just absolutely to
to endorse what dorothy said really
cares are our extended workforce across
health and social care
they're enabling people to remain in
their own home which is exactly where
people should be and so i would
absolutely support that
and the carers partnership is a drive it
needs to be that driving force and it is
it's growing in strength
i think going back to my point earlier
about mapping i want to
next step map everything that we are
already doing to each of the priorities
that eleanor is adding
to the health and well-being strategy
from this annual report
and then identify the gaps so the gaps
in where we're not driving things fast
enough to make the impact that we need
and we know that the um some of the
changes that covid has
has created and particularly things like
having elective
surgery when needed will have a greater
impact in the future and we need to map
some of those in um influences back into
the work and
work with martin and team around how
we're going to drive some of that
when we get to the other side of covid
but absolutely carers are part of the
health and social care workforce and
they are the top but
top priority for me and because it keeps
the
everybody's support going so thank you
dorothy
thank you diana um martin or sally do
you want to comment on well that's
by uncover them no i'd like to make
quick comments i think there's some
inequality amongst carers at the moment
because i think the um professional
carers
who are employed who are going into some
of our most vulnerable patients
fall into the jcvi cohorts one to four
so we are allowed to vaccinate them
but i have a lot of family carers who
are doing just as
just as an important job and i have to
bend the rules a little bit
in order to allow that family member to
get their code vaccine which to me is
just as important i don't want them to
take it into my most vulnerable patients
and that that annoys me because we
shouldn't have to and it also
underlines how we're valuing one set of
carers above a different set of carers
and i think that's something that we
need to address because family carers
are really really
important and i agree that they're an
unpaid and
just such an important part of the
workforce as far as the inequality in
the vaccine is concerned it's a really
difficult problem
particularly amongst some community some
communities that for
absolutely valid reasons are quite
distrustful of vaccinations and
vaccination campaigns for historical
reasons
but we are working hard to try and
challenge that and address that
and get the right information out and
offer the right reassurance
not so much in my part of the borough
because it's not
it's not as big a problem here but i
know louise grant is doing something
from um brooks bar and i think our old
governing body board
member priscilla quente i don't know if
people know priscilla but i think she's
volunteered to help get the message out
as well up in the north of the borough
so
we're very very much aware of it and we
know why people are reluctant to come
forward and
uh were ashamed of behaviors that went
on in the past
amongst uh doctors and scientists but we
are looking forward and trying to
get to those communities and reassure
them about this
thank you sally does anybody else have
any comments
council blackman
thank you could could ask sally a
question please
uh with regard to gp's um
getting information as to who our
carers who you know were on their their
patient lists
because it's you know it was it was sort
of i sort of mentioned this uh
it didn't take this early this week
about the fact that it's a very very low
percentage of
um of of carers are
recorded at gp practices and
how how can how can you know gps
you know increase this number how how
would it actually be done
i think there's two things so our local
authority colleagues
have got a list of carers that the
workforce
the paid workforce of carers so they are
being very helpful in providing that
with us because we don't necessarily
have people's occupations recorded in
our data
um and that would change so quickly i
think it's unrealistic to think that
what might be a pro
you know people change jobs so quickly
so we do rely on the local authority to
get that information to us and that's
and i think and will correct me but i
think all local authority
known carers will be advised how to get
their vaccine and i don't necessarily
think it's through the general practice
think they might be offered the mass
vaccination services but i think that is
being looked at
the problem is of course the the the
casual carers the the family members the
daughter-in-law this that the other
and we absolutely just rely on knowing
our patients i'm in a very small
practice so i do know my patients
so when i've got a daughter when when i
got my over eighties coming in for the
vaccine
the the first lot of vaccine we did
and you'll probably all have read about
this but we initially had vials that had
five doses of vaccine in the fisa vials
have five doses
and then it became apparent you could
actually get six doses out of every five
dose bile
and now actually we talk about them as
being six dose vials
but when i did my first set of my most
vulnerable patients my over eighties
we were still using a five dose vial
so in every vial there was a spare dose
and if the carer had brought their
elderly relative to my clinic who i knew
then we had an opportunity
to use a spare dose it wasn't at that
time it wasn't
a destiny for anyone else so we actually
managed to get people in an ad hoc way
it's not that that's saying it's not
really the right way to do it
it should be more stretched and
organized and we how we record those
carers i don't know
could i just ask sally would would a gp
in in the course of you know ever you
know an appointment
would would they ask somebody if they
did care for somebody or is that not
sort of the norm it wouldn't normally
come up in conversation no
not not no not if their their point was
about them
it'd be unlikely to just has an add-on
saying by the way are you a carer
i'm i'm just sort of thinking that maybe
you know especially
family members who are carers that's
that caring has
an impact on the individual's
physical emotional mental health etc
i'm just thinking that you know
information like that that
that added data can you know can add to
the whole
the whole jigsaw um
you know could something like that be
encouraged at all i think it probably
you'd but i would look at it from the
other side i would look at it when you
when you're
addressing this sort of annual check on
your house bound or you're vulnerable or
people that rely on carers
it probably could go in at that level
because
it it it's really because you
that's that's where i'd ask the question
i think perhaps yes they're not in our
routine checks at that stage
there should maybe should be a question
how do who looks after you
and then you could record it then
okay all right thank you thanks sally uh
councillor brophy did you have
something and just to add to the
conversation
about carers i wasn't intending to speak
on this but this is the
thing that's topical now i just say from
personal experience i think
often families work in teams to be
carers it isn't that you've got one
person caring in a family
it's often families pulling together and
it's a team where the family
makes sure there is somebody available
to care for the vulnerable person
whether it be elderly or
vulnerable for other reasons and i
wasn't going to
comment on that but my point was on the
report
and the thing about building back um
better or the conversation i wanted you
to add some points
i do think buildback better it's
it's no longer a good kind of phrase now
because
it hasn't got better has it everyone
knows nothing's got better
and i think buildback fairer is probably
a more accurate way of
describing where we want to get to but i
think
bill backfera it's kind of not a
complete description it's a good one
but i think that the way we are now
things are going to be different for
quite a long time
and with the cove it's not going to go
away we're probably going to need annual
vaccines for all our
vulnerable people and if not everybody
to make sure like the flu vaccine
because we're going to have new variants
pop
up over and over again it's not going to
go away seem to be the evidence
and we also think you know we're facing
other issues as well climate change has
been talked about
flooding has been really bad in trafford
so whilst we might be wanting to build
back fairer
and not better i think in a way we're
trying to build back differently
we're trying to build resilience and i
wonder if adding something about
building resilience
into that overall um arching thing would
be
fairer and more resilient perhaps
something like that that recognizes that
actually
it's not going to be going back to the
life of parties and freedom that we used
to have we're going to be restricted
for a little bit while longer in various
ways and
so those are my two comments
thank you jane and if we can then move
on do you want to
introduce the equality strategy um
eleanor
every time i tried to unmute my box
moved around i feel people have heard an
awful lot from me jane
and you did a really good job of it so
um
but again our equality strategy is very
much
in line but with some very very deep
with a detailed action plan underneath
it and some really
um focused pieces of work so i'm going
to say that about it and i'm going to
hand over to the chair
you're on moot jane
i was right on one then one time
20 to the dozen like normal that's been
the youngest of seven you see you have
to speak
fast and loud otherwise you never got
heard
so and yeah i was really pleased that we
were able to bring the strategy and
you know again i would like to thank the
officers for the hard work
across the ccg and across the council
for actually delivering
and you know the work on that strategy
it's
it's
really good it's going to be something
that we will um build on for the next
few years and hopefully we will be able
to um
see real improvements as it goes along
we don't want to see some big banging
at the end of the process we want to see
real improvements going you know going
forward you know we're talking about
being
an exemplar employer we're talking about
being um
a borrower of best practice those are
the things that we need to see we need
to see that real evidence for our
residents
i feel that you know kovid has
highlighted
really massive inequalities across our
borough you know when people look at
trafford they think of us as
you know this is really rich we're in
the south of
greater manchester and actually you know
we have massive pockets of deprivation
and they have got bigger during covid
and that can't continue so we do need to
have some
some much fairer ways of working make
sure that we don't leave people behind
so
you know the stuff that we're going to
be doing around
all the protected characteristics and
then looking at the wider
um and things that we will protect which
will be carers you know which will be
our armed forces personnel
all those other things that we need to
be doing you know we need to be
supporting those who
are in long term unemployed in in long
term
in unemployment you know so that we can
support them to actually and get back
into the work space
you know there's a massive piece of work
and and you know
i don't want it just to be that you know
this is where this is where what we
think we should be doing with
i can't wait to get my teeth into it
quite honestly because equality is
something that is a massive and you know
it's a massive issue for me
i was i was only saying to elena
yesterday you know i come from a big
irish family i'm the youngest out of
seven and my dad was
my dad was here now he would be a
hundred and a hundred and i think it was
a 102 this year
i mean one would have been 97 so you
know
i've lived in this massive generational
family and you know my granddad lived
with us until he was 94. he died in 1967
so
you know it's it's a massive it's so
close to my heart i have a sister who's
got a learning disability who
actually lived and supported living in
in trafford and she
is 73 and she had her vaccine yesterday
and was so happy when we facetimed her
because she thinks we can all go and see
her now but you know
it's really difficult and but you know
we have been going and seeing and
shouting
shouting to her from the pavement and
and i have a a mixed-race grandchild and
i have um you know
my family have uh mixed race um and
children as well so
you know we are we are we are a big big
melting pot in my family and
so that's why i'm so passionate about it
and i do really really
want us to succeed in this and it isn't
something that we've done in traffic for
quite a few years so
i just want everybody on board for it
everybody you know i want everybody to
contribute and i want us to be able to
deliver something and then in
2024 or 25 when it we know when when
we're ready to refresh it that actually
we can say
we did that and we made this improvement
for this group of people that's what i
want to see so
if anybody's got any questions around
and the strategy i'm really happy
to and take any questions or comments or
if we've missed anything in the strategy
that people feel that we need to include
please just speak or prank it
from great to manchester police oh yeah
sorry i've not had much of a talking
point but i just wanted to reinforce
what's already discussed today
if we get this right and make some
significant um improvements certainly
around some of the the early
intervention
um not only we see the the health of our
community better but actually we will
see reduction in
some of the stuff that we'll deal with
we've seen a massive rise
in mental health i'm really concerned
about domestic violence although
there isn't an increase i think all the
pressures we talked about
beginning of the meeting around working
from home
the challenges for homeschooling caring
etc
i am concerned that in the future that
it will lead to greater a
more increased relationship breakdown
and now we sort of
plan for that in advance but i think
this is a critical piece of work and
and certainly i have steps in for
caroline hemingway the superintendent
but we'll make sure that we we're really
behind it
thanks sean that's really really helpful
and last night at
the um health scrutiny helens grant
actually brought some information to us
around us
and you know the increase in well the
increasing and actually the exposure of
domestic violence across the border and
it's quite shocking really you know
and we think that it doesn't touch
everybody's life but it doesn't matter
where you come from
or you know what you look like domestic
violence is it can happen in it
in any relationship so and it was you
know that was a really important
and topic for us last night and so thank
you for be for what you said today and
you want to be able to support us and
contribute thank
it's really helpful to know the the
level of support
from the board around including these
additional
aspects of risk and um required
improvements
into the health and well-being strategy
so it really helps
i think eleanor to take that into the
next level and i think the
the steps for me are that we need to
update the strategy
we need to then map the work that is
currently underway on any of those
aspects
and identify any gaps in the work that
we're doing so that we can be really
clear how we
cover those gaps and allocate workouts
and then the board can
hold an overview of the required
improvements and try and set some
uh trajectories for that and then the
impact and deliverables from each of the
work streams that are held
within the sub boards and we can track
our
improvements because in 2025 as you say
jane i'd like to be able to say we have
improved these areas by x x percent
and we can we can really see tangible
outcomes for the people of trafford
thank you chair thank you so much diane
is there anything that anybody else
would like to say
okay thank you so much and
i think you can tell i'm really looking
forward to this piece of work
and and that uh pretty much
is to the end of the um agenda so
any urgent business i was just going to
add what we'll be doing after this
meeting is as diane says if people are
happy with this we'll be updating the
strategy sending it around with the gaps
the actions and so on for
for health and well-being board members
to comment on and
i think with some areas and work streams
we might be looking for
particular health and wellbeing board
members to be a champion for that topic
um so that you you ha you know that
as part of your role on the board that
would be about making sure we actually
are held to account and that we do
do get onto the delivery um because i
feel that that
that you know we need the ownership
across and we need your skills and
experience we need your
your your energy behind some of this to
make sure that it happens
so um that would be my ask
suggestion and then ask thank you and
jane you counselor if you'd asked
whether or not there was a date for the
next um board meeting
the date hasn't been set yet but
obviously we'll let people know
well in advance and so
if there's nothing more i'd just like to
thank everybody for today
and i think it's been really informative
and look forward to seeing you all and
next time
thank you thank you chair
thank you bye